-Our next guest is a talented
actor you've seen in
"The Deuce" and "Ocean's Eight."
He stars in "The Many Saints
of Newark," which is in theaters
and begins streaming on
HBO Max October 1st.
Let's take a look.
-♪ When will I...♪
-[ Sighs ]
-Hey, Sil, I need to talk to
my Uncle Dickie.
-He's not here.
-His car's here.
-Battery's dead.
-You know where he is?
-Who am I? Rand McNally?
-Please welcome to the show
Michael Gandolfini.
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Thanks so much
for being here, man.
I really appreciate it.
Come on up.
-Of course, thank you.
-Thanks for being here, Michael,
and congrats on the film.
I really enjoyed it.
I imagine, for any young actor,
it would be daunting to take on
the role of young Tony Soprano.
Plus, of course, you have
the element of being, you know,
your father's part
that he made famous.
-What was your -- What was
the process of going through
to decide you wanted to
take this on?
-Yeah, well, one of
the things that I think
was equally terrifying
and really helped was that
I had to audition
like three times.
So it was like
three months of, like --
first being like,
"I don't know.
You know, I don't know Tony.
I'd never seen the show.
I don't --
I want to be my own actor.
I don't really know if
I can do it."
And then, as the auditions
went on, I just sort of thought,
"You know,
you got to do a good audition
and get in front of
good people."
And I started to, like, fall in
love with Tony more and more.
So by the end, when it was like,
"We're going to do it,"
I loved Tony.
-That's really great.
-Yeah.
-Now, this is -- You mentioned
not seeing the show.
You were really young when
the show started.
-Mm-hmm.
-And, of course, your dad is
a completely different person
than Tony Soprano.
Did you -- Were you ever around
when he was rehearsing?
Was that something
you remember as a kid at all?
-I mean, not really.
I -- He was just my dad,
you know?
And he -- I mean,
he actually had this --
He had, like -- In his
apartment, he had this bookcase.
And he would, like --
It was, like, a secret door.
And you can, like, open up
this secret bookcase door,
and he'd go into his little
cave and he'd close it.
And it was, like, soundproof.
So, like, that's -- I remember
him going in there to, like,
run lines, and, like, him and
his coach would go in there.
But, you know, I never --
I ran around set.
I got fake black eyes
by the makeup crew.
And, you know, we'd be like,
"Dad, look."
But besides that,
I didn't really know anything.
-So, these are all, you know,
characters, obviously,
from the from "The Sopranos,"
but none of the same actors.
So none of the people
you've met over your life,
save for, you know, David Chase.
Did he --
-Yeah.
-Did you have a level of comfort
being with somebody like that,
who you've known, obviously,
your whole life?
-I didn't know David
personally too well.
I'd known him, but there's
a level of comfort as an actor
when you go -- I mean,
I'm walking into your world.
I mean, he would come up
and run and be like,
"You know, say this."
And, like, it'd be this amazing,
beautiful, funny line
that he would just
kind of come up with.
So it was a real comfort
to be able to go --
I'd call it, like
"The David thumbs-up."
Like, after every scene,
I'd be like...
"What do you think?"
And he would just go --
give me a thumbs-up,
and I'd be happy that
we got the scene.
-You are still a student at NYU.
-I am.
-You got to --
You made your own major.
Is this something that NYU kids
are doing these days?
-Yeah.
So, you can go to Gallatin,
and you create your major.
So, I mean, people major
in amazing things,
like, you know, dance mixed
with, you know, politics,
and they'd do some
incredible performance.
And mine's like,
I just go for character study.
That's how I formed my major.
-But character study --
does that --
that's not just acting, right?
-I actually have never --
I went to Tisch for
a semester and I left,
so I've never taken an
acting class at NYU since.
But it's a lot of, like --
I took, like, a
consumerism class to learn about
spending patterns in America.
And then I've taken
filmmaking and directing.
I took a class about
the history of penicillin
for my for my science credit.
So anything that has to do with
sort of people, you know?
Psychology, all those sort of
classes in that world.
-You probably
didn't need much help
as far as acting classes went.
As a young man, I mean,
I think we all remember
how you crushed Prince Charming.
I mean, just --
-Look at that hair, too.
-I mean, the hair is great,
but I think that
not enough people, when they're
watching people play Charming,
credit the look he gives
when he's staring at the shoe.
-At the shoe.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-This Prince Charming might not
be looking for Cinderella
as much as, like, he might
have a thing about feet.
-You know, "Into the Woods"
is a darker
sort of adaptation
of this fairy tale,
so maybe he had some sort of
foot fetish, you know?
-Your first day on set for
"Many Saints" --
which, I guess, this does seem
like a rite of passage
for anybody entering the sort of
"Sopranos" cinematic universe --
got slapped around a little bit.
-Oh, yeah, the scene was --
It didn't end up in the movie,
but Alessandro sl--
Dickie slaps Tony,
and Tony was like,
"Why did you do that?"
And then they talk a little,
and then Dickie slaps
Tony again.
Tony slaps Dickie.
They fight.
Johnny breaks them up.
And then Johnny slaps Tony.
-Now, when you get slapped
that many times,
how do you feel when
you're told the scene got cut?
-Yeah, well, it was --
I was pretty shocked.
I mean, it was -- We also only
shot that scene that day.
So it was like 12 hours
of three slaps a scene.
And Bernthal was like bra--
He would be like,
"You know, I'm a pro,
so, like, my slaps
don't hurt, right, Mikey?"
And you don't look at
The Punisher and go like,
"Eh, these slaps don't hurt
at all, man.
Like, I'm totally game."
And he's, like,
just hitting me hard.
Yeah, but it was --
It was great, you know?
It was, like,
the rite of passage,
like you said, and it was great.
-You also -- I guess,
was it your first film role
was "Ocean's Eight"?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I mean, I think people to this
day still say it's your movie.
-Yeah, exactly. It's my -- Yeah.
-I mean, a lot of
Oscar winners are in it.
-Yeah.
-An incredibly talented cast.
-It was amazing.
I mean, it was one of those --
You know, I played
Busboy Number 2.
-Yeah, of course. We all know.
-A privilege. Exactly.
And it was just
one of those things.
You get to go to
a giant set and sound stage
and think like, "I cannot
believe I'm here in the tux."
But that scene
took four days to film.
I have like four lines in it,
and it took four days.
The first day,
they didn't get to it
because they were
running behind, whatever.
The second day, a snowstorm hit,
so we had to --
We had to go to set
and drive back.
And then, the third day,
something happened again.
And, finally, the fourth day,
I got to deliver.
But I was, like, outside,
like, really, like,
rehearsing these like
four lines.
Like, I was really,
like, working --
-That's a nervous --
I mean, nobody, I think,
would not be nervous amongst
that group of people.
-Yeah. But it was amazing.
-You're amazing in this.
Thanks so much for being here.
Congratulations so much
on the film.
Thanks for making time for us.
-Thank you.
-"The Many Saints of Newark"
is in theaters
and on HBO Max October 1st.